françois cormier la question que le
maire de souligner la question en fait
c'est de savoir l'étendue des risques
pour l'environnement de la due au delà
du chiffre qui est impressionnant c'est
quoi les risques écoutez pour la pour
l'eau potable parce que c'est un
argument qui revient à chaque fois et
mieux vous le répéter pour rassurer la
population tous les experts qu'on
consulte la ville de montréal également
disent qu'il n'y a pas de risque pour
l'eau potable parce que l'ol est traité
lorsqu'on la prend une fois qu'on l'a
prise dans le fleuve c'est à ce moment
là qu'elle est traitée maintenant
l'autre question c'est est ce qu'il y à
des risques pour la faune et la flore on
est allé consulter un expert patrice
aujourd'hui monsieur paiement pierre
paiement de l'institut national de
recherche scientifique et qui nous dit
bayan n'a pas vraiment de réponse pas
qu'il n'y a pas de conséquence il n'y a
pas de réponse on ne peut pas savoir à
ce stade si si il y aura vraiment des
conséquences sur les poissons à ça peut
ça peut dépendre de la température qu'il
fait de ce que les montréalais vont
mettre dans leurs toilettes qui va
aboutir dans l'eau de l'endroit où tout
ça va vous dire exactement des courants
donc plusieurs détails qui pourraient
faire en sorte y aurait des impacts ou
non on peut quitter le professeur
paiement si les niveaux de polluants
atteignent un niveau trop grain en
fleurs oui qui pourrait avoir des effets
mais est ce qu'ils vont être plus grand
que ce qu'on peut percevoir à l'autre
bout
après les lots vache ou soleil vers la
station est donc vu dans les marais qui
sont plus loin ici
est ce que tout ça va changer
il va probablement y avoir un effet ce
qui va être mesurable peut-être même pas
bons on le voit donc ce n'est pas si
évident de statuer sur les risques et
par ailleurs le maire pendant sa
conférence de presse a dit il y en a
plein de projets dans le fleuve
puis on les laisse faire il a donné des
exemple oui parce qu'il semble que ce
soit connue par certains
moi je l'ignorais personnellement
patrice vous savez qu'à montréal il y a
une usine d'épuration donc la quasi
totalité de l'eau s'en va à cette usine
pour être traités mais cette usine
elle enlève seulement essentiellement ce
qui est solide de l'eau donc tout ce qui
est virus problème microbiologiques un
lit certains liquides toxiques
continuent de passer et ça sert jeté
dans le fleuve depuis des années à
l'heure actuelle on écoute à nouveau le
professeur paiement tout ce que vous
déversez par vos toilettes en votre
évier les produits pharmaceutiques les
usines qui travaille sur l'île de
montréal qui déverse là dedans
dans ces égouts collecteurs là c'est
tout tout est là en pratique
l'usm d'épuration qu'on a maintenant à
montréal qui recueille toutes ces eaux
là qu'on va déverser n'est là que pour
enlever du gros morceau du sam un peu de
matière organique et du phosphore les
produits chimiques et les migrants mais
passent au travers en direct ce qui fait
dire donc à certains que la pollution va
augmenter avec ceux des versements
prévus le 18 octobre mais pas nécessaire
sera pas nécessairement différent de ce
qu'on vit à l'habitude et juste pour
vous mentionnez en 2018 d'une usine de 2
à nation qui devrait être inauguré à
montréal qui fera en sorte que cette eau
là qu'on va racheter à sera désormais
meilleur que les actuels mais vous du 18
octobre c'est loin d'un tueur plus
qu'ottawa la vieillerie nerfs et tout ça
en suspens alors ça pourrait être
parions après les élections ah oui à lui
voir mathieu pro seront soir on va pour
conclure ce bloc essayer de comprendre
d'où ça vient ce problème là pourquoi on
en est là aujourd'hui remonter à
l'origine d'origine c'est ce secteur là
le secteur de l'autoroute bonaventure
pourquoi parce que cette autoroute
ce ne sera bientôt plus une autoroute on
veut en faire un boulevard urbain un
boulevard urbain ça veut dire quoi se
dire ah bé c'est toute la structure
comme on le voit sur cette animation ça
aof au niveau du sol donc il faut faire
des travaux il faut faire des travaux de
structure en sous sol il faut déplacer
la chute à neige la suze à neige qui se
trouve en ce moment au niveau de la rue
wellington on la déplace quelques
centaines de mètres plus au sud vers la
rue riverside très bien mais qu'est ce
que c'est une chute à neige exactement
on en parle depuis une semaine voici son
c'est immense trou dans la chaussée dans
lequel les camions ou viennent déverser
des tonnes et des tonnes de neige
pendant l'hiver ça c'est la partie
émergée de l'iceberg
si on va en sous sol on voit que toute
cette neige tombe dans une immense
conduite qu'on appelle un collector est
à peu près à 35 mètres au sous sol
cette conduite ici fait parfois jusqu'à
5 mètres de diamètre voyez ici de tunnel
on peut presque passer des wagons et il
faut assécher tout ça pour quoi
pour assurer la sécurité des
travailleurs qui vont le vrai sur le
chantier a séché ça veut dire quoi plus
rien qui va dans cette conduite on voit
les espaces clairs sur cette carte là ce
sont ces zones qui envoient leurs eaux
usées dans l'intercepteur du sud est
toutes les eaux usées les pluies les
eaux des résidences les industries etc
donc il n'y aura plus rien il ya au bout
ici la station d'épuration dont parlait
françois tout à l'heure voici ce qui se
passe dans cette station d'épuration et
sont donc ces eaux là qui vont aller
directement dans le fleuve où ça pas un
seul point mais dans 24 points en tout
tout au long de la rive sud de montréal
donc voilà vous pouvez aller voir cette
cette carte là sur notre page facebook
très clair mathieu merci elle en a tout
compris on verra maintenant la seule
question qui demeure est ce que la ville
de montréal va convaincre les autorités
fédérales d'aller de l'avant
comme je dis à françois ce serait fort
est un hack ça se produise avant quatre
vingt le 19 octobre la campagne
électorale
merci nature